the inhumane realities of the 30s and
the 40s the 20th century a reality today
but this is the answer to that for us is
no no we are defending
we're defending from the anti-european
most anti-european force of the modern
world we are defending ourselves from we
ukrainians on the battlefield together
with you
[Applause]
thank you
and we must defend ourselves and it's
important not only for the states of
Europe not only for the communities and
Societies in Europe no matter who we are
and what we are we're always fight
against disrespect
and neglect wherever we live we're
always
faith in Integrity forever for whatever
we dream for our children and
grandchildren yeah and the precondition
for these dreams is peace and security
and that is going to be and whether it's
going to be possible if we do not
overcome the anti-european force that is
trying to steal from all of us
no only our Victory
will guarantee all that
[Music]
of our European values
I have a victory that is going to be
that should be should happen that would
be mandatory